mírame a los ojos un segundo eres gay no
mírame los ojos un segundo
eres gay no ya les dije que hacen
atención a jubilee presenta reunimos a
siete hombres heterosexuales soy
heterosexual antonio del sexo soy
heterosexual soy hetero soy heterosexual
soy heterosexual soy heterosexual
uno de ellos miente si el grupo descubre
quién es el intruso se repartirá en el
premio
pero si el mentiroso permanece hasta el
final ganará el impostor
ronda rápida levanten la mano si alguna
vez han tenido novio te atraen
sexualmente los hombres
no pero puedo admirar un buen hombre
bien tiene sentido llevas un anillo de
bodas el ciere cuando te casaste hace
ocho años ocho años muy bien cuál es el
nombre de tu esposa stephanie a ustedes
le creen al principio jonathan me empezó
a interrogar debido a mi anillo de bodas
chicos quién ha besado o ha sido besado
por un hombre me besó un hombre a mí me
vestí a mí también me besó el hombre
quién de ustedes beso un hombre y le
gustó no está claro si malo empezará un
hombre una vez veces sin querer a uno de
mis mejores amigos en mi cumpleaños
mi novia estaba allí nos vio creo que
fue una ronda muy productiva si todo
está muy claro vaya pero ahora qué
hacemos ruina rácano el supertazón
acaso eso importe no me gusta el fútbol
no creí que él fuera el intruso pero
cuando estaba votando pensé debo seguir
mi estrategia debo ganar
soy el único al que le hicieron una
pregunta se preocupe en este tipo de
episodios a la persona que expulsan es
la única que le hacen una pregunta
segunda ronda alguno de ustedes ha sido
confundido con un gay quién crees que
ocurre eso creo que es por mi voz en
claro que soy gay y no sé si no lo sé
quizá sea por mi acento california no
creo causó muchas muletillas siempre le
confunden con un gay tú creo creo que se
pueda saber si una persona es gay por la
ayudarían exacto es por lo que ha vivido
y cómo saber si una persona es gay o no
por su apariencia física no creo que sea
posible fue una conversación que intente
al llegar pero cambiaron rápido el tema
creo que parece que esto funcione
debemos hacerle preguntas a uno de
nosotros y que los temas analicen lo que
responde hagan me preguntas oye mírame a
los ojos un segundo eres gay no lo sé
es muy difícil formar equipo y acusar a
una persona si lo hace
la persona gay puede usar eso a su favor
y esconderse detrás del oído sabes oigan
saben que aquí
jonathan todos miren a jonathan ahora
bien
y ellos creen que la persona actuaría
diferente por por ser gay me hizo gracia
porque es una mentalidad de los 60 y
pensé no vamos a sacar nada de esto
alguna vez has visto un pm he visto
muchos penes y cómo te sentiste con eso
no me sentí sexualmente atraído por
ninguno de ellos esta es la cosa a veces
cuando te estás cambiando en un vestidor
normal él está intentando desviar la
atención de los demás en mi mente pienso
es el intruso wesley tienes novia no
tengo no conoces personas en este
momento preferiría estar soltero una
temporada está muy bien me parece buena
idea y hablo en respeto explica suave
bien en cuando tuviste tu primera novia
tuve mi primera novia en la universidad
sí aunque no estuvimos mucho tiempo
juntos bueno lo que pasa es que soy
musulmán y tener citas es por lo general
no muy común y limitado así que es
normal ser gay en la cultura creo que en
lo que respecta a la religión ser gay no
es
si eres muy devoto yo diría que sí
cuando era más joven y va a la mezquita
es un asunto sino preguntas no te digo
es un tema que merece ser tratado
debería haber mucho más amor y menos
odio no se debería discriminar a las
personas por hacer y ser quienes quieran
ser como es tu relación con tu padre es
buena
pregunta si sus padres no los inventó
sin generar polémicas y tal vez sea la
razón no soy un cretino última persona o
pregunten
pero no lo hace solo hago desgracia
siempre alguna vez y sustituyó pues no
lo entiendo prefiero centrar mi atención
en una sola persona quién es esta
persona un hombre o una mujer mujer por
supuesto
[Risas]
carlos no sé cómo funcionará está
funcionando has besado a un hombre él
dijo que si lo hecho que está ocurriendo
es decir esto que sea un chico porque
pensé que podría hacer
y en eso se convertirían incluso por ser
sexualmente fluido en el estrés pero si
tienes más del 50% ustedes son son
homosexuales actualmente no juegan se
acabó
y
e
[Música]
nos vemos luego jason nos vemos amigos
levanten la mano si piensan que el
intruso todavía está en el cuadrado y
les gustaría continuar el juego tenemos
que estar seguros tercero que basado en
toda la interacción creo que se que
señalar a alguien es malo y me disculpo
por eso pero es un juego eso y luego
creo que eres gay verdad creo que por
eso siempre intentas dominar la
conversación y es lo que me indica tu
lenguaje corporal me pareció que se
estaba comportando muy macho quizá él
estaba exagerando el papel de
heterosexual y bien veamos a wesley mira
su tatuaje en el brazo derecho
hay tres cruces entiendo que representan
la crucifixión muy bien creo que él sea
gay han conocido a muchos muchos
cristianos gay es un presentimiento es
más probable que no lo sea que sí lo sea
así que no tendría sentido votar por él
votaré por wes eso es lo que lo que
apesta chicos que nos hicimos amigos y
siento que ya no lo somos así razón de
esto vamos por una cervecita y me
gustaría ir en muy bien muy bien así que
se suprimieron
luego saldremos en una cita no si tú
quieres sólo les diré que no me
molestaré si votan por mí muy bien
hagamos eso pues están pensando que
alguien es gay y ha resultado ser cierto
no creo en ese tipo de cosas existe una
verdad liberal pero no todo el mundo la
conocí hermano él es gay y cuando salió
del closet guau me tomó por sorpresa por
ello creo que los estereotipos no
siempre son verdad pero alguna vez te
pasó por la mente alguna vez imaginaste
que fuera gay no nunca volvemos las
veces cuando no estás prestando atención
cierto es fácil no darse cuenta me
entiendes cierto sólo pensé que entiendo
lo que significa sé a ti mismo por no
saber reconocer cuando alguien es gay o
de no estar seguro sin embargo creo que
no es lo suficientemente pasamos los
primeros cuatro minutos discutiendo cómo
íbamos a descubrir al intruso y yo
estaba diciéndoles chicos
debemos darnos prisa que es lo más gay
que han hecho crecer mis amigos y yo nos
metíamos los dedos en el trasero los
unos a los radios
la situación
es tan heterosexual soy coreano en corea
hay un juego llamado cancha en el que
los niños se le acercan por detrás a sus
amigos y la inserta en el dedo en el
trasero así al mismo tiempo que grita en
cancha oye por qué te alejaste
básicamente me pareció gracioso pero
también pensé bien te creo no creo que
seas gay que es lo más gay que has hecho
no lo sé me encantaba el teatro en
escuela ahí lo tienes eso es tu turno no
lo sé creo que me preocupo mucho por las
personas que amo soy muy normal
acaso en eso es que he escuchado
personas decir ese chico es muy amigable
y les digo ok si lo soy
eso es bueno
y creo que lo más gay acerca de mí es
que me encanta dar masajes a los hombres
a cualquier persona igual cuando le doy
masajes a un hombre algunos me preguntan
si soy gay y yo eso importa pero como se
presenta esa situación le preguntas te
podemos ayudar les doy masajes con su
consentimiento son mis amigos y cuando
estamos juntos me dices como amigo
estaba haciendo con sus amigos
está bien como si haces este tipo de
cosas no eres que es probable que no
seas gay
muy bien creo que lo más gay acerca de
mí sería mi gusto musical me encanta
beyonce también sigo aprendí spears
desde el primer día ese es el tipo de
música que me gusta me encanta el género
pop creo que sería lo más gay bien estoy
en aumento
está bien 760 del acerca de la
homosexualidad en la comunidad musulmana
si no hay problema creo que muchas
organizaciones religiosas han adoptado
ese enfoque conservador en el que forman
parte de la religión pero no les
permiten hacer nada si fueras gay te
sentirías cómodo saliendo del closet la
estaría cerecera romper que no estoy
siendo sincero por mí porque sé cómo son
los musulmanes
evans hablo mucho cuando le hicieron
preguntas dio respuestas rápidas y pasó
a la siguiente persona
hubo un empate o sea wesley y evans
ya no quiero juzgar puedo irme a casa
[Risas]
[Música]
i
siempre pensé que west era el gay quería
dividir el dinero con evans pero pensé
si todos están siendo codiciosos
entonces yo también seré codicioso con
los demás quark siento que nos
deshicimos del intruso en esta ronda sin
embargo no siento que esperaba
seccionada no creo que lo hayamos hecho
me estoy poniendo en riesgo de nuevo
pero está bien que west es el intruso
esa es mi opinión
ahora bien les propongo tomar el dinero
y dividirlo entre tres creo que eres una
persona muy creíble y siendo honesto te
creo pero prefiero lo seguro
porque soy musulmán es una buena jugada
y también lo entiendo si de verdad lo
entiendo en este juego cualquiera puede
mentir y pensé esta es una jugada muy
buena así que pues la verdad o es una
mentira porque sacó la carta de los
musulmanes quiero entrar y lo estás
diciendo es que él está jugando y que
por lo tanto es gay así que sea o no sea
no creo que sea la mejor estrategia así
que lo aseguro es votar por él
este es el episodio sobre inmigración
en pakistán luego de decir eso pensé y
rayos esta no fue la mejor estrategia
que use él se comportó de una forma muy
madura y entendió el contexto del juego
esto apesta amigo chicos usted no lo soy
oye y somos amigos no te juzgaremos
vamos con esto miren sus zapatos él no
puede ser gay
este bromeando es verdad jonathan te
quiero pero si eres el intruso eso
estaría muy mal lo que puede hacer fuera
de estas manos hoy el intruso cuarta
ronda
ni siquiera sé en quién confiar me
siento muy descorazonador
y tienen esa fue la estrategia sí verdad
para ser sincero me sorprende haber
llegado tan lejos en el juego jugué la
carta que me pareció más fuerte y dije
que saben que soy musulmán no puedo ser
yo levanta en la mano si quieren
continuar el juego debemos hablar de
esto un segundo
vamos continúa el juego continúa lo
llevamos continúa el juego continúa el
juego yo amigo quiero dominio porque soy
competitivo pero creo que el intruso
está fuera terminó el juego no perdimos
la confianza tienen que confiar en mí
se torna roja dio intrusos sigue en el
juego y ustedes pierden confirme si la
luz sorda verde ustedes sacaron al
intruso y ganan
no creo que eres gay ganamos
y yo tenía razón amigo sigo sorprendido
todo este tiempo pensé que era juez
estoy feliz de haber llegado tan lejos
verán algunos sospecharon de mí al
instante y otros como ves no tenía ni
idea en ningún momento pensé que iban en
el intruso lamento haber sido amigo por
cierto el teatro no es eso si lo que
pensé me puedes dar un abrazo espero que
entiendan que las personas son mucho más
que su orientación sexual esa es la base
del respeto nosotros no podemos buscar
tan rápido la orientación sexual de las
personas estaba muy sorprendido este
juego cambió la opinión que tenía con
respecto a los estereotipos puedo no
mencionar una última cosa gracias a esto
tomar el dinero y lo donaré a el
proyecto trevor así es eso es lo que
haré espera
como este tiempo pensé que tú eras el
gay
jubilee vive intensamente